[MUSIC PLAYING]
JOHNNY LEE: Hello, everyone.
Let's see.
Where's my slides?
Welcome to the afternoon,
the second day of I/O.
I hope everyone is
enjoying their time here.
My name is Johnny
Lee, and I'm here
to give you a little bit
more information about where
we are with Tango.
If you saw the keynote, which
probably most of you did,
you got to see a little bit.
But in this session, we
get to see a lot more
and go into a lot more depth
than we could otherwise.
So I wanted to start
with this quote
from Beau Lotto,
who's a neuroscientist
from the University
College London.
And he said that, "The best
technologies are ones that
make the invisible visible."
And an example of
that is a microscope.
It's a tool that
allowed us to see
more things about our
environment-- things
that may have always
been there, but they
let us see things in
a new way and give us
a better understanding
about how the world works,
and also changes the way about
how we view ourselves as well.
And most of our
devices today view
the world as a flat screen.
But we're physical beings
in a physical world,
and we wanted to add
to the capabilities
to understand 3D with Tango,
adding ability to sense motion
as well as a depth of
objects and services.
So if I place this bottle here--
oh, this doesn't
have a flat surface.
Well, if I place
the bottle here,
its mere physical presence here
is meaningful to all of us.
I can refer to it and talk
about it in a way that all of us
understand simply because
of its physical presence.
And it's because of the
way our minds have evolved.
And if our tools understood the
fact that this bottle was here
before, we would have a shared
understanding with, not just
the people in this room,
but also with our tools.
As a quick refresher, Tango
has three new capabilities
for mobile devices.
We add motion tracking, depth
perception, and area learning.
And you'll learn
a little bit more
about the large scale
area learning from Justin
that we call the visual
positioning service.
First let's take a quick
recap of the hardware.
So as you may know, the first
device that came out with Tango
enabled device capabilities
was a Lenovo Phab 2 Pro.
This came back last
fall, and it had
all the hardware we needed
to do these capabilities.
And our second generation
phone is the Asus Zenfone AR,
which is a 5.7-inch phone that's
both Tango enabled and Daydream
ready, with a Quad HD
Amoled display and a sleek,
thin design.
It's a really,
really nice phone.
We're also pleased to mention
that, in light of the summer
and Verizon stores
across the store,
customers will be to
play with a Zenfone AR
across the United
States, with 11
international other countries
coming in the summer as well.
In addition to the phones,
as you saw in the keynote,
we now support standalone
headsets for VR,
and we've been working on a
specialized version of Tango
that does tracking in 3D.
So we used two fish eye cameras
and all of this LAN technology
built into Tango
to allow six degree
freedom positional
movement in a VR headset.
Now, we all know that
hardware is merely
the vehicle that carries
new experience to users,
and it's the software that
brings those experiences
and value to our users.
So let me show you a really
short video just showing
some of the great work that's
running on the platform today.
So that's just a
really short glimpse
into some of the 100 apps
that have now been available
on the Play Store since
these phones came out
just a few months ago.
I'd like to highlight
just a few of these
in three different categories--
games, shopping, and tools.
In games, Electronic
Arts recently
released an update for
their Sims FreePlay, which
allowed you to use Tango to
walk through the environment
of the houses that
your Sims live in,
in a first-person perspective.
Lego BrickHeadz Builder AR
is a character building game
where you can see
your characters come
to life in front of you.
You can build your
own custom models
or work with some
of the free models
that they provide in the game.
Hologrid Monster Battle,
from Tippett Studios,
creates a turn-based chess
game right on your living room
table, where you can use
combinations of monsters
to try to defeat your opponents.
Now, one area we've
seen a lot of value,
in particular for 3D
visualization, is shopping.
Pottery Barn released an
app called 3D Room View that
uses Tango sensors to place
products from the catalog
right in your room so you can
see how it will fit and look
with your existing
furniture, and you can also
clear out the furniture and
start from an empty room
from scratch.
BMW iExplore lets you verify if
you're interested in a BMW i3,
if it's going to be a
good fit in your garage.
You can also check out
the much higher end i8,
if you're curious about that.
You can check out all the
interiors, configure it.
You can look at the
dashboard and chair details
just by moving around.
One of the areas that's
particularly hard
is shopping for clothing
online and having a good fit.
So, Gap has been working with
a company called Avametric,
which does physically
accurate simulation of 3D
models and clothes.
So you simply pick the mannequin
that best fits your body type
and you can see
exactly how different
sized clothes will fit and
stretch when you wear them.
In addition to
these partners, we
have several other partners
interested in making
applications they can help
you make better decisions when
you're shopping
online with your phone
or helping you
shop in the store.
Now, tools is also a really
interesting category,
and it helps create
a new class that
gives you the ability
to make measurements
about your environment.
And it's great for people who
are trying to get work done.
Just to give you a
few examples of these,
we also have a clip
of what partners
are doing in this area.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Our goal was to
develop an app that
lets you create a floor without
actively drawing on Magic.
And Magic Plan is the first
app that lets you do that.
Before Tango, we were using
the RGB camera and a broader,
noisy IMU to capture a room.
But we had to prevent the user
from moving during the capture
process.
The odometry, depth
sensing, and RGB camera
allow us to semantically
classify and locate
everything you see
through your device,
and all of that in
a matter of minutes.
- Trimble has combined
Google's Tango technology
with a lightweight, centimeter
accurate GNSS receiver
to create a high accuracy
outdoor mixed reality system.
Using paper plans on site
to providing a real world
understanding of future space,
relative to today's space.
- Just [INAUDIBLE] stage series
investigation and installation
stage in the pavement
construction.
- Recently, we
were in the middle
of mechanical coordination at
the General Motors Technical
Center Research and
Science Building.
We had modeling of the
facility, but there
were gaps that
needed to be filled
to ensure the systems
would work in compressor.
We were able to
use a Tango enabled
device to capture
missing information,
verify clearances, and keep
coordination expedited.
- Cat Liveshare is a live
TelePresence application
that gives us live audio, live
video, and also introduces
augmented reality annotation.
The difference with
a Google Tango device
is that it's mapping
the world at real time,
and we can actually annotate
on this side of the machine,
spin around it and annotate
behind us, and come right back
and those annotations
are still there.
So there's a huge benefit
for us going from one place
to another, but also keeping
that history of where
you've been around a machine.
- My name is Matt Whelan,
and I'm a VFX supervisor
in Toronto, Canada.
I use Google Tango
and an amazing program
by matterport called Scenes
for on-set data acquisition.
You get that basic
texture information, lots
of volume metric information.
Most importantly, you
get it at world scale.
Meaning, your actor's 5'4",
now you have that on record,
but you also get the
wrinkles in your costume,
or the certain way
the actor stands.
How big is that your
doorway or that prop?
Google Tango and
matterport Scenes
make that kind of on-set
data acquisition easy, quick,
and efficient.
[END PLAYBACK]
[APPLAUSE]
JOHNNY LEE: Thanks.
So those just give you a
glimpse into the kind of things
that genuinely save
people time or money
to get their jobs done, and
we see the value of Tango
being able to provide more
of that to more people.
In terms of demos, one of the
things I wanted to highlight
was one of the Sandbox demos.
How many of you have actually
been to the Tango Sandbox?
OK.
That looks about a
third to a half of you.
One of the demos
there that I like,
that I think is really
great, is this one
called "Somewhere,"
or "Welcome to Oz."
And when you walk
into that space,
all you see is these
empty floor and two walls.
But with the work of a
team up in San Francisco,
trying to better estimate
lighting and shadows
and reflections to make
AR content blend better
with the environment, when you
look through the Zenfone AR--
oh, there's a video.
Is there a video?
Back one more.
That one.
Yes.
That's a really fun experience,
and if you go to the Sandbox,
you can get a selfie taken
with one of the characters just
like this.
But with the right work
and focus on lighting
and shadows and
reflections on the floor,
the compositing
of the characters
can look very realistic.
So let me give you a demo
of some of these live.
And switch to the phone.
So the first one I'm going
to show you is an app
called Holo, which is done by
a company called [INAUDIBLE]
based in Los Angeles.
So in addition to
animated characters,
we can actually also do real
world characters, or real life
people.
So what they have
is a capture system
with a large array
of cameras that
allow you to do a live
performances of people,
and capture them in full 3D.
So let's add someone that you
guys may be familiar with.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Well, hey, it's
great to be here.
Sorry I couldn't
be here in person,
but I did the next best thing,
which was sending my hologram,
because holograms are cool.
Well, hey it's great--
[END PLAYBACK]
JOHNNY LEE: So I can walk around
and look at him from a bunch
of different angles.
And so you can bring any live
actor, or any live performance
in their studio, and
capture them in 3D
and place them in a
space just like this.
Because they are
virtual and 3D, we
can do something a little
bit more fun, like this.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Well, hey, it's great to be--
[END PLAYBACK]
JOHNNY LEE: We'll do this one,
and we'll shrink him like this.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Whoa!
OK.
Now that is a big water bottle.
Huh.
[END PLAYBACK]
JOHNNY LEE: So this
is a lot of fun,
and it just shows
you what's possible
when there's more and
more content out there,
and people building these
type of 3D experiences.
We also have made a bunch
of SDK improvements,
and one of the ones
I want to show you
is something that we've been
calling Com, internally.
But it's basically online drift
correction and map building.
So if you have this app, which
is our built-in measurement
app, the measurements
are only useful if they
stay attached to the world.
And drift correction
is something
that we've had turned on as an
experimental mode for a while,
but we've been making
some optimizations
in the performance of it so that
we can run it real time, all
the time, with minimal
impact on the applications.
So if I shake the phone and
basically lose tracking,
it locks back on and brings
back the measurements
to the same space.
So if you update your SDK--
yeah, I think that's a cool one.
So this keeps contact
registered to the environment
even if the user walks away
or puts it in their pocket
and brings it back
out, as long as it's
within the same session.
So if you update
the app and you work
in one of the
current SDKs, you'll
have this online drift
correction for you
automatically.
So can we go back to the slides?
We also have a few other SDK
improvements I'd like to share.
This one is our
constructor developer tool,
which we also have being
done out in our Sandbox area.
And it's our first
party 3D scanning app,
and I just wanted to
show you a video showing
some of the updated results.
So this is all data that's been
captured with the Lenovo Phab 2
Pro, and also processed
on the Phab 2 Pro.
And you can see that the
quality of the reconstruction
is actually pretty good.
It's not fully photorealistic,
but you get a pretty good sense
of the environment and being
able to walk around and see
some of the details and
get a sense of the space.
Now, one of the cool things
is that, with the Asus phone,
it's both Tango enabled
and Daydream ready,
so not only can you
scan a room in full 3D
and get these kind of captures,
but we added a VR viewing mode.
So with the press
of the button you
can then put it in
a Daydream headset,
and actually through
the apartment
you just scanned, using the
Daydream controller to teleport
through this apartment.
So it's pretty amazing
that you can do all of this
with a phone that
fits in your pocket.
We've talked to some
developers, and not
everyone knows what
to do with a 3D model.
A lot of real estate developers
and facilities management
simply want a floor plan.
So we took some of our
algorithms for 3D meshing
and just export a 2D plan,
so that you can walk around
and get an estimate of
the walls and the doors
and the furniture.
One really interesting thing
is that the developer that
worked on this
realized his apartment
was actually 50
square feet smaller
than it's supposed to be.
So you genuinely
could use this to try
to renegotiate your rent
if you felt like you
were getting charged too much.
We also have gotten feedback
that better occlusion tools
and sample code was desired.
So we now have,
coming soon, examples
of real time shaders that
combine data from both the RGB
camera and the depth camera
so that you can do effects
like this really very easily
and without a lot of hassle
of writing your own code to
figure out how to do this well.
Also, some sample code on
using data from the RGB camera
to improve environmental
elimination.
Those shadows and lighting
and changes in the environment
add a lot to the
realism or the effect of
whether or not something
looked like it's really there.
So you can see the reflection
of the notebook and the mug
in this pool ball.
There are still some ways to go
before we are Hollywood quality
special effects, but this
isn't bad for a real time
capability on phones.
We're also happy to
say that, if you're
one of the developers that
worked on one of the 40,000
vuforia apps currently
in the Play Store,
vuforia now has native
Tango integration.
So your vuforia
apps will continue
to work on a broad
range of phones,
but if they're run
on a Tango phone,
they'll benefit from
an additional features,
such as the smart terrain system
that processes their point
cloud, and better tracking
from our fish eye camera.
So we're really happy to
welcome augmented reality
community that's been
around for a few years.
Another exciting
thing that we wanted
to give a little bit of detail
on was WebAR and Chromium.
So today, if you want to take
advantage of the benefits of AR
and be able to place objects
in the person's room,
you'd actually have
to convince the user
to find your application,
download it from the Play
Store, and install the app.
But just like with
Web VR, wouldn't it
be great to just go to
a URL and suddenly you
would be able to download and
pull all the assets right away.
So if we could view
AR content as easily
as we could view images
or video on the web,
that would be really great.
So this is actually a early
prototype of Chromium web
browser at a Wayfair
web site, and you
can see that the motion
tracking data, the depth data,
are all actually piped
directly into the web page.
And what the person
has done here
is actually drawn out a
box in their living room,
and says, well, what tables
will actually fit in this space.
And Wayfair responds
with the tables
that will actually
fit the constraints,
and is able to place and render
that object all inside the web
browser.
So as you think about being
able to discover content
very easily, we view this
as a really interesting way
to make it much easier for
people who own 3D assets
and want to get more
viewers on those 3D assets
to get users much more
quickly without having
to pre-install a specific app.
Now, to tell you
a little bit more
about location in AR and our
visual positioning service,
let me hand it off to Justin.
JUSTIN QUIMBY: Thanks, Johnny.
Hi, everyone.
My is Justin Quimby and
I'm a senior product
manager on the Tango team.
And we've made a lot of
progress in the last year
on location based AR, and
I'm thrilled at the chance
to show off what the
team's been working on.
So Clay mentioned the
visual positioning service
at the keynote, and I'm proud
to say that the service already
has apps running on it today.
The first app which
launched on VPS
was an app entitled
Lumin, built by GuidiGO
and running at the
Detroit Institute of Arts.
Lumin enables both navigation
to exhibits and digital content
when you arrive
at those exhibits.
So here you can see, in the app,
a visitor getting navigation
to a specific exhibit.
Now, this is using no Bluetooth
beacons, no Wi-Fi maps, or GPS.
This is entirely
visual navigation.
And then, once you
get to the exhibit,
you can then see
digital content overlaid
on top of the real world.
So here you see a CAT scan of a
mummy in the real environment.
So this allows visitors,
through the Phab 2 Pro,
to see through
the outer wrapping
and revealing the
skeleton underneath.
And as a result of this
overlay of digital information
in the real world,
visitors can actually
see the really large crack
on the skull of the mummy.
And this blending of
the real and the digital
means that visitors are actively
engaging with and learning
from the mummy, rather
than walking into the room
and saying, hey, it's
a mummy, and leaving.
And in part because
of this, Lumin
won the American Alliance of
Museums annual competition
for the Games in Augmented
Reality App category
in part because the app delivers
meaningful visitor outcomes.
And we've also launched
an AR experience
at the Art Science
Museum in Singapore,
which you saw at Johnny's
keynote this morning.
This app transforms over 1,000
square meters of the museum
into a virtual rain forest,
which you can explore
using your Tango device.
And "Into the Wild,"
which is the app,
is made by the Art Science
Museum, Google, Lenovo,
and the World Wildlife Fund,
in association with Panasonic,
Qualcomm, and working with Media
Monks and a Singaporean artist,
Brian Tan.
And in April, the
Singapore National Museum
also launched a Tango
based experience using VPS.
So this app lets visitors
explore the museum
and see how it's evolved
over the past 130 years.
And so, this floating
whale skeleton
used to be in the museum, but
was transferred to Malaysia
in the 1970s.
And so now you have
parents taking their kids
and explaining to
them what they used
to see when they were
kids visiting museum.
And since it's a digital
object placed in the world,
it can actually show not just
the skeleton, but a full whale.
And not just a static whale, but
also a whale and how it eats.
And it's not just museums that
have launched apps using VPS.
Earlier this year, we launched
the treasure hunt experience
in conjunction with an
MGM Grand in Las Vegas.
And this app allows players
to go on a digital treasure
hunt for coins
within the Casino,
and they can use those to then
try to win real world prizes.
And Google succeeds when
our partners succeed.
And we're fortunate to
have one of our partners
here today with us, Kyle
from Lowe's, to talk
about how they built on
top of the Tango platform
to solve real problems
for their users.
KYLE NEL: Cool.
Thanks.
Thanks, Justin.
So when you think of Lowe's,
you don't necessarily
think of emerging
tech like Tango.
Every organization
on the planet says
they want to create the
new disruptive tools,
but that's harder than it seems.
There are two things
you have to figure out.
What you want to work on, and
what you don't want to work on.
So to figure that
out, we get people
together inside and
outside of the company
to work on those things.
You need an intuitive
way, though,
to be able to help people
understand the future.
That's a hard thing.
We do that through stories.
So we create actual
narratives about the future
we want to build,
and then we work
backwards to bring it to life.
This is a scene, actually,
from our first story
that we turned
into a comic book,
and it turned out to be the
most disruptive tool we've ever
built. One of the hardest
things about home improvement
is that it's really, really hard
to envision how your project is
going to turn out, and
even harder to communicate
that to the person
you have to convince;
to communicate that
to somebody else.
So it's estimated that about $70
billion in projects every year
go unfulfilled, just because
of this visualization problem.
So we knew that we could
use visualization tech
to build new tools that could
help solve this problem.
And we used the comic book to
show our executive team what
the future would look like.
And it's all about bringing
those intuitive solutions
to life in order to
influence human behavior.
It's not about building
tech for Tech's sake,
and our executives'
reaction to the comic book,
after seeing what we could
do, was to go build it.
So we did it, and
four years ago, we
brought the first iteration of
that augmented reality design
solution that we call
the Holoroom, into two
of our Canadian stores.
So it was really
early-- four years ago--
and the tech was rough.
But we use our stores as
living labs that would show us,
so we could get real feedback
from actual customers
and employees, not just to
create solutions that work,
but solutions that actually
work for real people
and our customers.
And we talked about what we
were doing really loudly,
and the intention of
that is to attract
more what we call uncommon
partners, the kinds of people
and organizations that
you wouldn't expect
a Lowe's to work
with, that could
help us achieve this narrative.
So Google was one of
our earliest partners
to respond to that call.
And from the earliest days
of exploring AR and VR,
we worked with Google to push
the future further, faster.
And in fact, in the
second generation,
as you can see here,
of the Holoroom,
we created a Google Cardboard
vending machine, that I love,
to give customers a
take-away VR experience.
Once again, not
about creating stuff,
but creating stuff that works.
But really, it's
not about VR and AR.
This kitchen vignette
is what you typically
see when you come into
one of our stores.
Our benchmark is not "what's
the best AR and VR experience."
It's the way customers
visualize today
that is decidedly low tech.
So when we are building
experiences that are so far
from moved from where
customers know today--
this kitchen vignette--
how do we measure
what's working?
So we quickly found that
the right tools didn't
exist to evaluate if
people like something
that they've never experienced
before, something truly new,
like Tango.
And my background is actually
in behavioral science,
and I teamed up with
some of my partners
from academia to take
the latest research
and turn it into an
implied neuroscience tool.
So this worked.
This turned into a company
called Neurons Inc.,
that anyone can use.
And the real reason is you can't
trust people's stated reactions
to tech that's so new.
One of the things I
always hear is, I love it,
and they take it off and
never put it back on again.
So neuroscience allows
us to tap into customers
unstated reactions through
a variety of measures.
We've completed thousands of
hours of neuroscience testing
on different AR and
VR technologies,
and our studies showed that
the busy kitchen vignettes were
causing cognitive overload,
as you can see here
in this bar, and low emotional
engagement and motivation.
And then, next, we tested
all other VR and AR tools,
and they did better, but they
were still too overwhelming.
But when we tested Tango,
even early on, with customers
we saw for the first time that
they had the optimal level
of cognitive interest.
They were more engaged.
They were also more
motivated in a positive way.
And all of this
meant we had finally
hit upon a truly
intuitive experience.
So last fall, we celebrated
our first ever global launch
of the Lowe's Vision
Tango app, which
allows customers to
measure their space
and select virtual Lowe's
products to fit it.
At the same time, we launched
the Lenovo Phab 2 Pro
at Lowe's, introducing the
next generation of what
we call digital power
tools, and the phones
sold out in just a
few days after launch.
Think about that--
Lowe's selling phones.
And since launching
Lowe's Vision,
we've had a really
positive response
from customers who are excited
about how comfortable it
is to design and personalize
their homes using
this platform.
Now we're excited to be
an early partner bringing
the visual positioning
service to our stores.
We've launched in-store
mapping in two stores
to help customers
find products faster.
And based on a positive
response so far,
we are excited to
announce that Google will
be mapping 400 more stores.
Just to give you
an example of what
it's like to use this app in
our store, check out this video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
- Well, here we are inside,
and if you're anything like me,
you get to these places and
you're like, oh, my god.
Where do I even start?
But fortunately, I happen
to have a Tango phone
right here, which
is going to help
me get from product to
product and buy exactly what I
need way faster than I normally
would be able to get there.
So let's have a look here.
So I'm just going to open
up the Lowe's app here
and then pull up
my shopping list.
Now, this stuff is
all over the store,
and normally you'd be
like, where is any of it?
With this, what I could
do is just navigate,
and my phone is going to tell
me, OK, we're over this way.
75-foot outdoor extension cord.
OK.
We've got that.
Next.
OK.
And a number nine-- pretty good.
Number nine.
Got it.
- Oh, hey, what's up?
- What are you doing here?
- Shopping for the boxes.
- Four-inch hex bolts.
Check.
We got some hex bolts.
[END PLAYBACK]
KYLE NEL: Great.
Thank you so much.
Justin, thank you.
JUSTIN QUIMBY: Thanks, Kyle.
Partners are a critical
component of the Tango
ecosystem, and we're thrilled
to be working with Lowe's.
And a common thread
of all these location
based AR experiences
you've just seen
is they're built on top
of the visual positioning
service, a service
for developers
to map indoor environments,
and then create
location based AR experiences.
So let's get into the
details of how it works.
The visual
positioning service is
comprised of three components--
mapping, cloud processing,
and client localization.
The first step is that
of creating a map.
So, in a venue
which has given us
permission, such as
this Lowe's store,
collection involves
walking through the store
through the main pathways
with a Tango device.
With a wide angle
camera, combined
with the motion tracking
capabilities of the Tango
Stack, it creates a data
set of the environment,
which you can see on the right.
When this collection
pass is completed,
the data gets uploaded
into the cloud, which
brings us to our second step--
the cloud processing pipeline.
So here's a visualization
of an aggregation
of all the different mapping
runs for a given Lowe's store.
In every frame, we're detecting
hundreds of visual features
to compute the 3D location
of corresponding points
in the scene.
These collected data sets
are then processed, aligned,
and compressed, using
middle-out, into a cloud map.
This mapping is based on
purely visual feature tracking.
It doesn't need Bluetooth.
It doesn't need Wi-Fi.
It doesn't need GPS
to create this map.
And every capture and
recapture of a venue
is incorporated to the
map and improves it.
An important note here on size.
One of our larger venues
that's currently running on VPS
is a shopping mall, over
900,000 square feet.
And in that shopping
mall, we use
over 1.3 million key frames, 37
million landmarks, and over 300
million key points to provide
localization of anywhere
from a centimeter
to five centimeters.
So this is a scalable system
to tackle not only your living
room, but massive,
massive indoor facilities.
Now, once VCS has completed
its cloud processing step,
we now have a map
of the environment
which any Tango enabled
device can localize against.
So let's return to
that same Lowe's store.
And so this is a video
of a device localizing
in a Lowe's store.
Now, just as you can control
the permissions for GPS
on your phone, so, too, do you
have control over apps that
have access to VPS permissions.
To be able to
localize in a space,
the user needs to give
the app permission
to use both the camera
and location permissions.
Once the user has granted
those permissions,
as it moves through
the environment,
it's looking for visual
features and matching those
against the stored cloud map.
This provides continuous
adjustment and alignment
between the device's position
and all the AR content which
has been placed in that space.
So VPS provides you, the
developer, a coordinate system
to overlay digital content
into the real world.
The CAT scan of the mummy, all
the products in a Lowe's store,
and the treasure
hunt in the MGM Grand
all use the same
back end service.
And today, we have
over 150 buildings
mapped and running on VPS.
So, great.
You've got a little bit more
information about how VPS works
and its capabilities.
How do you build for it?
So today, VPS is
in private beta.
If you're interested
in developing for VCS,
please go to
developers.google.com/tango
and sign up to get more
information as we bring more
and more developers onto
the platform over the course
of the coming months.
But what you can do
today is build an AR app
based on Tango's core
capabilities-- motion tracking,
depth sensing, and
area learning-- which
are foundational for creating
great AR experiences.
And the final step is
to start thinking about,
what would you build if
you had a persistent AR
layer over the world?
And as you saw at the
keynote with Expeditions,
when you create experiences that
allow multiple people to have
a shared experience
across multiple devices,
not only are you adding digital
content to the real world,
but you're also adding shared
meaning to these interactions
among people.
And we believe that's one of
the most powerful aspects of AR.
And VPS allows for the creation
of persistent and transient
maps of space on which people
can experience the same AR
content together.
And VPS is a tool.
We're building to enable
you to create amazing,
location based AR experiences.
We can't wait to see what you
build on top of this service.
Let's all aim to build
experiences which
bring our users joy like this.
So with that, I'd like
to hand it back to Johnny
to talk about the future.
JOHNNY LEE: Thanks, Justin.
It's really great to see
the past year of progress
we've made with content partners
and our location service
over the past year.
But I'd like to leave
you with a glimpse
ahead, just a sample of
what we've been working on
as research projects, either
internally or externally,
to paint a little bit
of the road ahead.
And some of these are
done with partners.
And it's important to say
that these aren't necessarily
things that will
be in the roadmap
or no deterministic ship date.
But it gives you
a sense of where
things are going over time.
So we can play the video.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
[MUSIC PLAYING]
I think that drone
video is pretty sweet.
So, that's some
of the work we've
been doing with partners in
experimental and research work.
But over time, we hope to start
to bring more and more of these
into the platform so that
people like you can use them.
Over the next 12
months, the team
is working hard to
bring Tango capabilities
to more and more
devices, be they
phones or standalone headsets,
and we do expect that number
to grow rapidly.
And we do believe that, one
day, all our phones will
have some form of this
capability built in.
As you saw in the
video, the ability
to have indoor, precise
positioning and tracking
capabilities, like
VPS, will enable
new types of spatially
aware computing,
and enable new devices in
the wearable space and even,
in the future,
robotic platforms.
There's a lot of
exciting work to come,
in working with more
of you, the developers,
create new experiences that
enhance the way we play,
the way we shop, or
find our way in stores,
or new ways of learning.
And Tango allows us to
interact with digital content
in a physical way, bringing new
forms of immersive computing.
So for more information, please
see our developer web site
or consider joining the
Google Tango developer Google+
community.
It has over 12,000 developers
posting videos and links
to new apps on a regular basis.
Thank you for joining us,
and enjoy the rest of I/O.